[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROB DODSON: Hey, everyone.
What's up?
It's Rob Dodson.
Today on Polycast,
I'm going to show you
how to take your
entire application
and make it run offline,
all without writing
a single line of JavaScript.
This is crazy,
wicked awesome stuff,
so follow me and let me
show you how it's done.
So this is your web page today.
When it needs an
asset, it goes off
to the network to request it.
A network fetches that
asset and then returns it
so it can be displayed
on the screen.
But as we know, this back and
forth is not always so perfect.
Sometimes the request
could take a long time
to get to the network.
And maybe the network
takes a long time
to send the response back, or
it takes a long, roundabout way
to do so.
Perhaps the user loses
connectivity along the way,
dropping from 3G to EDGE.
Or maybe they lose connectivity
entirely, in which case
the network is just unavailable.
So there's a lot of reasons why
this back-and-forth dance is
not always as seamless as
we would like it to be.
Now let's look at the
same model, but this time
with Service Worker.
So Service Worker
is a new standard
that acts like a proxy, letting
you intercept network requests
in JavaScript and then
allowing you to handle them
how you see fit.
So the user makes a request,
which flows through our Service
Worker.
And when the response comes
back from the network,
the Service Worker can decide
what it wants to do with it.
It could, for instance,
create a cache
and actually store the
response in that cache,
and then return it to the user.
So the next time the user makes
a request for the same asset,
the Service Worker
can check the cache,
see that it's inside of
there and return that instead
of having to hit the network.
This basically enables a
really nice offline model.
Now, there are a bunch of other
things that you could do here.
You could have
the Service Worker
hit the network and the
cache at the same time
and make the two race.
There's a ton of patterns that
are detailed by my friend Jake
Archibald in this
offline cookbook,
and I really encourage
you to check that out
after you're done
with this video.
But what if you're in a
browser that doesn't have
support for Service Worker?
Well, in that case,
you just go back
to the way things were before.
Your page tries to
hit the network,
and the network sends
back a response if it can.
Nothing breaks in this
model, and in that way,
Service Worker is just a
progressive enhancement.
And that's why Service
Worker is kind of brilliant.
If you have a
subset of your users
that can support Service
Worker, well then
they get an enhanced
experience, something that's
a little bit more engaging.
And for your users
that can't support it,
because perhaps their browser
doesn't implement it yet, well,
they're going to get the same
experience that they get today.
So it's not a matter of
choosing whether to use
Service Worker or not.
Instead, you can look at Service
Worker as an additional layer
that you can add
to your application
to give some of the users
a much better experience.
I think this is pretty awesome.
And if you're interested,
there are actually
strategies around using things
like App Cache as a fallback
if Server Worker
is not supported.
In general, if you're
interested in learning more,
there's this really
great write-up
by Matt Gaunt, which goes
into a lot of detail.
There's a lot of really
good material out there,
so after you're done
with this video,
definitely go do a bit of
additional research there.
Now, to set up your
own Service Worker
usually involves a
fair bit of code.
You've got to configure your
registration and [INAUDIBLE]
and caching and la-la-la.
It's just, like, crazy.
Now thankfully, there's
an element for that.
Thanks to the new Platinum
Element collection
from the Polymer
team, you actually
get Service Worker
support for free.
It's already set up in
Polymer Starter Kit,
and so I'm going to
show you how to use it.
This is what we're
going to build today.
It is a very typical
Polymer Starter Kit app.
You can see here, though,
that as I'm using it,
I can set it to Offline.
I can then go and click
around and use the app,
and it will continue to work.
I can even click this button
to load an image of a map
from the network, and
that works as well.
So how do we do this?
Well, the first thing
you've got to do
is go and download
Polymer Starter Kit.
You can grab it off of the
site at developers.google.com.
Then you're going to want
to go to the GitHub page
for Starter Kit and check
out this guide on enabling
Service Worker support.
It's actually pretty easy.
You just need to uncomment
a few lines of HTML
and then add this
little precache gulp
task to the bottom
of your build file.
Now, some of you might wonder,
why is this disabled at all?
Why not just have Service
Worker running by default?
And in fact, in previous
versions of Starter Kit,
it was enabled by
default. But what we found
was that can be very
confusing for users
who weren't expecting
Service Worker to take over
their local host port.
And suddenly they
were developing
a completely separate
site, and they
were seeing the offline
version of Polymer Starter Kit.
So because there was some
confusion around that,
we decided to make
Service Worker support
an opt-in feature.
So that way when
you're using it,
you know exactly
what you're getting.
OK, let's go through the steps
to add Service Worker support.
The first thing
we're going to do
is hop into our index.html file
and scroll all the way down
to the bottom of the page.
And you'll see this block
of commented text here.
So uncomment that.
Inside of here, we've
got a paper toast,
which is a little
notification that
will display in the corner
letting the user know
that their app works offline.
We've got this platinum
Service Worker register
element and then a platinum
Service Worker cache element.
So the Service Worker
register element
is what is actually going to
create and register your Server
Worker in the document.
It has a few important
attributes I want to detail.
The first is this
auto-register attribute.
This tells the element to
go ahead and actually set up
the Service Worker
and kick it off.
If this was not
here, you would have
to write a little
bit of JavaScript
to get that process going.
This skip-waiting attribute
tells the Service Worker
to skip the waiting phase and
go right to its active phase.
Normally during a
Service Worker update,
it's going to wait to see if all
of the user's tabs are closed.
You know, you might
have multiple tabs open
on the same site.
It would wait to see if
all those were closed
before trying to activate.
In this case, we're saying,
don't worry about that.
It's OK if they have multiple
tabs on the same page open.
Just go ahead and do your thing.
This last one, clients-claim,
tells the Service Worker
that once it is activated, it
should go ahead and immediately
take control of
the page and start
intercepting fetch requests.
So combining these two is
a pretty powerful pattern.
Now, the cache element
that you see down here,
it's going to handle
adding files to the cache
and returning those to us.
And it's got this default cache
strategy, which right now is
set up to be network
first, meaning
it's going to go off to the
network, and if something 404s,
then it's going
to hit the cache.
You could set this
to cache first,
or you could even set
it to, like, cache only.
There's a few different
strategies here
that you can work with.
Lastly, you've got this
precache file attribute.
And the precache JSON here is
a manifest file of file paths--
it's basically an
array of file paths--
that we want the Service
Worker to precache
for us once it boots up.
So these are things that maybe
the user hasn't even seen yet
but we just know
they're going to need,
so we're going to tell
the Service Worker,
grab all those assets
as soon as you start.
I'm actually going to come
back to this in a little bit,
but let's move ahead
now to look at what
we need to do to get the
rest of this working.
So over near elements
HTML file, we're
going to go down
here a little bit,
and we're going to
uncomment these two imports.
These are for our
Platinum Elements,
and now they can
load into our app.
We can run gulp-serve.
We can boot up our local server.
It's actually going to open the
browser for us when it's ready.
And then we can
see our app here.
We'll notice in the
bottom left that we
get this notification
that caching is complete
and we are working offline.
And, in fact, we can verify
that by opening up our dev tools
and turning on Mobile
Emulation mode.
And you can see I'm
going to go in here.
I'm going to use the network
throttler to throttle
the page so that it's offline.
And then we can refresh.
Our content will
continue to load.
We can open our sidebar.
We can click around.
You can see that the
different routes are loading.
So this is looking pretty
good, but we go to Contact page
and we click this
little button down here,
and our image is
giving us a 404.
So what's happening?
So at this point, Service
Worker is dynamically
caching assets as the user is
navigating through the site.
But what I want to do
is ensure that that map
is available to the user
even if they haven't actually
visited that page yet.
So to do that, I'm going
to have to tell the Service
Worker to precache an asset.
Let me show you how to do that.
OK, so the asset that we want to
precache is this map JPEG file.
And if you recall, I said that
there's this precache JSON
thing, which is like
a manifest of files
that we want the Service
Worker to cache for us
even if the user
hasn't seen them yet.
So if we wanted to add
some files to that,
a really simple way to do so
is to add another attribute
to this element.
And this attribute is
just called precache.
And we can pass this
attribute an array-- that
is, a JSON array.
So notice how I'm using
single quotes on the outside
here so that I can use
double quotes on the inside.
That's because JSON only
takes double quotes.
We can give it a JSON
array of file paths
that should merge into
that precache JSON.
So with just this
one file path here,
my app is actually all set up
and everything's going to work.
But as I was doing
this, it really
got me thinking, like, what's
the deal with this file?
Like where does it come from?
How is it built?
What's inside of it?
So for that, we're going to
go inside of our gulp file.
And we've got this
precache task that we
can look at inside of here.
And what it's doing
is it's building
a little glob of file paths.
And a glob, if you've
never heard of that before,
is basically an
array of file paths
that are generated
using this string.
And this string is sort of
like a regular expression.
It says, match anything in the
elements directory, anything
in the scripts directory,
anything in the styles
directory, any subfolders,
any files in there.
So it's pretty
wide open, anything
in any of those directories,
match it and add it
to this manifest file.
We've also got this
line right here
where we're pushing individual
files into that array,
like our webcomponents
polyfills and our index file.
So if you needed to do
something like cache
an entire folder full of
assets, rather than put that
into the precache
attribute in our HTML,
we could actually
drop it in here.
We can say, cache everything
in the images directory.
That's one option.
And if you wanted to pass
just individual files,
another option would be to add
it to this little push call.
You could do this,
although it's probably
easiest to just do
this in the markup
because it's just a
single attribute there.
But I wanted you to know
about how this thing worked
and the options that
are available to you.
And the last step
in this process
is to make sure
that we have enabled
the precache task to run inside
of the gulp default task.
So we'll add precache here.
And what this does is
it ensures when someone
is doing a distribution build
that it generates that precache
JSON file for them.
At this point, we're done.
Everything is going to work.
We can hop back
over to our browser.
We can refresh the page.
You'll notice that I've set
throttling to Offline again.
And I can go and click around.
And as I get to that
Contact section,
I can click on the
Show Me the Map button.
It's going to hit the network
or, in this case, the cache,
and load in our map image.
So like I said, this
is freaking cool.
You've got your entire
application working offline
and you didn't
even have to write
a single line of JavaScript.
It just magically
happened, thanks
to the power of web
components and Service Worker.
That's it for today, folks.
If you have questions,
please leave them down
in the comments.
I do try to read
all those if I can.
Also, be sure to click that
little Subscribe button so you
don't use miss any episodes.
Again, thank you so
much for watching.
I'll see you next time.
Hey there, Polycasters.
Rob here.
Q&A time.
This week's question comes
from Dr. Robrez-- so hi there,
Doctor-- who asks,
in Polymer 1.0,
can we do data bindings
inside of our styles
like we used to be able to
do with the old core style
element?
Or is the recommended approach
to do data bindings inside
of your class names?
So, for instance, you might
have like class foo bar
and then a data binding for
another class called baths.
So a really good question there.
In Polymer 1.0, you cannot
currently do data bindings
inside of styles.
That is something
that we're thinking
about putting on the roadmap,
but right now there's
no real ETA for that.
Also, you cannot do binding
expressions inside of strings.
So the recommended approach is
to take your entire class list
and generate what is called a--
or I guess what we're calling--
a computed binding out of that.
So you can check out
this link right here
to read about doing computed
bindings down in the docs.
These are pretty cool.
You can pass arguments
to them and it
can return a string, which
will fill out your entire class
list for you.
So really awesome question.
Thank you so much
for sending that in.
If you have questions,
please leave them down
in the comments.
We try and read and answer
all those if we can.
And maybe we can feature you on
the next episode of Polycast.
Again, thank you so
much for watching.
Be sure to click that little
Subscribe button down there,
and I'll see you next time.